[Music]
as we approach the end of 2023 let me
ask you something what do you think
about this year as an anime fan me I
think it's pretty damn awesome sure
there were some low points like constant
production delays but I guess with the
grind and rigor of the seasonal Anime
schedule some things just can't be
avoided the good points and the highs
more than make up for it however and I'm
here to share with you what I think of
the 20 most amazing anime 2023 has given
us starting things off we have mashall
[Music]
ER if the Goofy character designs and
the bright colors remind you of
something else then you're not alone and
what better anime to pay homage to than
one of the biggest titles of the 2010's
one punch man mashall in a lot of ways
feels like a knockoff not just to one
punch man but to other popular
intellectual properties like Harry
Potter too you've got the crazy
overpowered character who's quiet and
unassuming you've got the magic skull
you we' got the techniques and the
over-the-top fights that are common in a
lot of Shonen and it's all awesome Mash
simply proves that you really don't have
to be super original in order to be a
success it may seem like a point of
criticism actually to call many bits of
the show knockoffs but practically
speaking it really isn't as I believe
it's mostly execution that matters here
at the end of the day anime is here to
entertain us and with such a funny way
of parodying anime tropes and
overpowered protagonists mashall proves
to be a
winner
next we have the first of many new looks
of old faces triy gun
[Music]
Stampede bringing back Legacy series and
giving them the modern treatment in the
form of remakes has been a thing the
past couple of years now of course we
shouldn't expect them all to be remakes
as these new retouches aim to tell the
story from different angles or
approaches they've mostly succeeded in
varying degrees although there are
instances like shine King where things
just had to be rushed like the anime
team just wanted to get it over with
thankfully though try gun Stampede isn't
that and as a fan of the original I
quite like the new approach they took
with this one try guns a franchise
that's always amazed me with its world
and strong thematic elements it's been a
pleasure being able to join Vash in his
adventures back in the '90s and I really
don't mind how this modern version
instead decided to focus more on The Who
and the how of things it's a
character-driven affair more than the
predecessor and it places more emphasis
on hammering down the conflict between
the brothers Vash and n try gun Stampede
had some rough stretches in terms of
reception to its CG but I never found it
to be jarring enough to take away
enjoyment from this cool show whether
you're a fan of the OG or a new fan
looking to get into the franchise try
gun Stampede should definitely have
something for
you my happy marriage is one show that
you don't want to
miss shows that go all in on the drama
and tragedy aren't exactly mainstream
hits of a season even a known tear
jerker your line April still had a
bright and positive outlook enveloping
the anime's run as such I didn't expect
my happy marriage which is a fitting
title to set the anime world on fire and
be a trending show or anything like that
actually but don't let that dissuade you
however because if you're looking to
find yourself in a whirlwind of emotions
and witness a kind of anime with a
different feel from what you're really
used to then this is one of the best
that 2023 had to offer my happy marriage
doesn't pull back or mince words when it
comes to the Fate of the characters
there's a sense of suffering and despair
lingering in this series that feels
quite cynical than what we've come to
expect from fiction still that doesn't
change the fact that is nothing short of
amazing in the story buildup Department
as well as incorporating art and music
in bringing out those heavy emotions the
character work is impeccable and
thematically speaking I really like that
no matter how much heavy drama there is
there's always a sense of hope no matter
how Bleak things may be the anime also
hammers in the fact that things could
turn for the better it may be muted
subtle and all of that but it's never
less there forming a strong Foundation
to an underrated
show you hear that it's the sound of the
hottest mobile game to hit the market
I'm pleased to welcome today's sponsor
reverse 1999 a 20th century strategic
RPG that's sure to take you on a trip
down memory lane so what's the buzz
about reverse 1999 takes place in a
world where spellcasters known as
arcanists coexist with Humanity it's the
year 1999 and instead of time
progressing on its last day it's
suddenly began flying backward in a
phenomenon called the storm you follow
vertin the only archinist immune to the
effects of the storm as she looks to
unravel the mystery behind this
phenomenon and that my friends is the
backbone to an interesting game whether
it's the fun gameplay you want or the
unique premise and aesthetic reverse
1999 is looking pois to be the next
Breakout game just for you the gorgeous
looking skill animations are just a
cherry on top of this very addictive
game The Game's now available in both
IOS and Android as well as PC whichever
way you want to experience the game
click the link in the description in
order to get some release perks I'm
talking about up to 73 summons and a
guaranteed six-star character within 30
summons talk about a great way to get
you started on the adventure hope to see
you in game Undead girl murder is for
those who like their fair share of
whimsical
Mysteries integrating the supernatural
with Mysteries and setting the story
against a Victorian backdrop has proven
to be quite a successful formula Undead
murder fast takes a crack of that setup
to a good amount of success giving anime
fans a great crime- solving anime that's
full of suspense it relies quite a bit
on shock value yes but it also doesn't
take away from the fact that the series
boasts some likable characters with
great chemistry and a plot that's quite
fun to follow atmosphere is always
something to look out for in this genre
and I do think it's one of the strongest
suits for the anime it really helps
supplement the nice character Dynamics
and the banter which makes up the other
part of what makes a show like this
click for me mystery may not be the most
popular genre around but we have a
diamond in the rough here you
know we have another remake as the next
entry on the list ruroni
Kenshin in the same vein as try gun
Stampede ruroni Kenshin 2023 looks to
bring a beloved '90s classic up to speed
with a more modern take it retells the
classic story of Kenshin the wandering
swordsman looking for Redemption and
swore to never kill again in a style
more similar to the original manga that
means way better animation and a cleaner
look than the original especially those
of us who've been around to watch the
original may have found it a bummer that
the comedy was toned down I get that
take and I do agree to a certain extent
but like what I said with try gun
Stampede I don't think that that change
is bad at all this new version of
Kenshin aims to retell the same
legendary story with a slightly
different approach and I think that the
more accurate adaptation kind of makes
up for it it's an opinion that I'll find
myself reiterating in another Revival of
a much beloved show down the line
personally I simply find it cool to see
these popular anime of yester year get a
modern rendition like this it feels
feels like a reunion with old school
friends and this time everyone looks
better and acts in a way more apt for
the modern era there's a lot of love to
put into this remake in places like
Faithfully adapting The Core Essence of
the story I'd say and watching it put
the skeptic in me to
rest zom 100 brings zombies back to the
spotlight in
2023 doesn't seem too long ago when
zombie flicks were all the craze it's
like a trend that comes every few years
it fades off and then returns in a
slightly different form literal zombie
of a trend if I may well I don't think
zom 100 is here to bring back the hype
for the zombie movie but it sure manages
to blend that concept with something a
lot of young adults feel in this day and
age of stressful work conditions and O
Bleak Outlook of the future combining
some Modern dilemmas that resonate with
the youth and their cynical Outlook of
the future as wage slaves with a zombie
survival setting seems to be a decent
enough setting but what helped push zom
one 100 to prominence is just how great
everything looks to say that it's
cinematic in quality especially in the
first episode is an understatement with
newer fans placing more and more
emphasis on art quality and animation as
a barometer of what constitutes a good
anime Z 100 manages to Surge towards its
status as the biggest upand Comer now
then the unfortunate release schedule is
something else
though Dr Stone New World marks the
first sequel to be featured on this
[Music]
list
Dr Stone has been an adventure anime to
talk about from one season to the other
the anime manages to take on various
elements and genres and make them as
immersive and captivating as they could
ever be we all know Dr Stone is the
educational shown in anime but whether
it be exploring a new world or an
emotionally charged conflict between
opposing ideologies the series just
makes it work with that being said
expectations were pretty high as the
cast takes on their next challenge in
the new world and it ended up being a
voyage to remember a fun adventure story
and Great Character Dynamics continued
to be the Hallmark for Dr Stone a new
world doesn't let up in any way as far
as those are concerned as we gain new
layers of intrigue regarding the
petrification that kickstarted the whole
plot and meet new characters that shake
up the dynamic even more there's even
more reason to keep watching Dr Stone
I'm pleased to say as well that it's
generally maintained the good quality
story and World building that started in
its first
season up next is Hell's
[Music]
Paradise if you want something with a
bit more Edge in your adventure anime
hell's Paradise could be your calling
the premise of an immortal convict
setting sail to an island of danger with
fellow convicts and his executioner
seems thrilling enough but wait till you
see the actual action sequences one
thing hell's Paradise always did for me
is have me on the edge of my seat of how
intense the best actions sequences were
I also felt that the character and World
building is really good in this anime
and the excitement never lets up per
episode due to a mix of the mentioned
intense action sequences and the
unexpected deaths and turns in the
narrative one thing that people have
noticed you know that ends up being to
the show's detriment is its Reliance on
narrative there's a lot of narration in
telling us about the Island's dangers
and all of that so do keep it in mind
when deciding to watch the anime still
it's a pretty nice watch if you want
more hard-hitting action in your
adventure anime it's still fresh into
its run but I can't help but feel your
[Music]
free talk about a latecomer to the anime
of the Year sweep Stakes freen is a full
2023 anime that I had high hopes for it
aired and broke those expectations
creating a wonderful story that defines
what a complete anime looks like in 2023
you know the thing with free rent is
that it excels in so many areas which
makes it such a great anime to recommend
to anyone looking to get into the medium
the story is well paced and World
building remains one of its strongest
suits and then you add to that the
contemplative yet hopeful mood and
multifaceted characters that embody
those ideals as well as visuals that are
nothing short of breathtaking and you've
then got what I call award-winning
Cinema in anime form if you got a friend
looking to get into anime and is more of
the type who prioritizes strong
narrative and character building over
cool action sequences then this would be
my pick for the whole of 2023 what the
show in the hype factor I mean not that
it needs any given its themes and genre
it more than makes up for with pretty
much everything that critics and pundits
would love in an
[Music]
anime Demon Slayer has come a long way
now hasn't it it no longer feels like
the Juggernaut it once was with a new
competitors rising from the Horizon
still it continues to do what it does
best and that's give us eye popping
fights with spectacular visuals the
visuals and the sound have always been
Demon Slayer strong suit and what
propelled it to become the Behemoth that
it is things seem to have taken a bit of
a downturn though but that's to be
expected given that the swordsmith
village was coming off a Hy Ark and was
more focused on character building over
the fighting still then it delivered
when it needed to giving us a couple
more moments to remember we're now
approaching the end game and I can see a
bright future ahead for Demon Slayer the
last few clashes against the upper moons
will be glorious and I hope you're going
to be there to witness
it let's continue bringing out the big
guns now up next is mushoku tensei
season
2 muso cense is always a subject of
discussion in the anime Community for
many reasons and it's continued to bring
more of the same Buzz with its second
season with a new season comes new
challenges for our protagonist who
finally has to come face to face with
one of the challenges in adolescence
heartbreak suffering a worse for than
ever and finding a renewed Vigor to seek
out answers regarding his life he
continues his adventures through the
Northern Territories mushoku tensei has
maintained its status as a do it or
isekai that looks pretty and really
emphasizes character growth it's one of
the more direct anime in terms of
following a protagonist's footsteps as
he continues his March through life and
his challenges exploring not only new
lands but also so new feelings within
himself there's still more action in
this second season but the mood is
generally more somber and
reflective we move on to osin noo for
the next
entry around the middle of the Year OKO
was the hottest property in town it's
one of the most popular anime and it's
not hard to see why it didn't waste time
putting itself in position to make a
statement a movie length opener with an
amazing ending a narrative that's just
so immersive and characters who all
exude Charisma while they struggle
through all to relatable dilemas there's
so much to like about osin noo and
that's not even talking about how it
shows the rigor and less glamorous side
of the entertainment industry osoko is
an anime that expertly knocks some dark
truths into the face of its audience
before shifting gears and showing that
there's a good and dreamy sign to all
the struggles at the end of it all the
characters and how they were written
form the backbone of Oso's rise they've
no doubt been the most integral part of
the story and when you put them into
challenges brought about by the plot you
got a series that you just can't let go
of the second season is on the way too
so you better get yourself up to speed
with this one
now blade of the Guardians lands in the
top half of the
list
if there's something I've learned from
covering the best of Chinese anime is
that they spare no effort when it comes
to animation these are shows that don't
have a lot of marketing aren't exactly
appealing to the typical anime audiences
at first glance and often get buried
underneath the Blockbusters of every
season yeah watching them I develop a
sense of appreciation for the effort and
flexing by the animators pushing a
decent to good story to something that
I'll gladly vouch forn recommend 2023 is
Testament to that is none other than the
blade of the Guardians a story that's
pretty simple in premise but shows its
Excellence when it comes to characters
in animation a story of a man accepting
dangerous missions in ancient China that
inevitably escalates tenfold may seem to
be a plot that's not unique but it all
hinges on the execution and the way
blade of the guardian's moved with its
plot I can't help but keep wanting more
historical anime are also something I
like so that could have played into why
I ended up enjoying this one so much
actually this is something you can give
a chance if you're looking for those
Diamonds in the Rough in the world of
anime barely any marketing but in it
lies one of the most captivating stories
2023 has given
us Bongo stray dogs is in its fourth and
fifth seasons for this year and it just
keeps getting
better Bongo stray dogs has the
distinction of being anime that just
keeps getting better season after season
while the same getting better late down
the line can be said of many shows Bongo
stray dogs manages to sustain that
upward trajectory that a lot of popular
series can't having lull periods in
between epic arcs for example to put it
simply this franchise has only gotten
more and more interesting and it still
remains underrated for how good it's
become a lot of it has to do with how
the stakes have become higher now
compared to before I've seen a couple of
people know that this was the first time
threats felt super real for some of the
characters something that I'm actually
inclined to agree with with how well
this season has done in the character
development department it adds to the
thrill and suspense of waiting for each
episode and wondering what twists the
story has left to throw at its
audience the hype for Heavenly delusion
wasn't misplaced and it ended up being
one of the best anime of the
year
I've got to admit that I didn't know
what to make of heavenly delusion at
first a post catastrophic world with an
isolated Society that's not exactly what
it seems on the surface what I love
about Heavenly delusion is how it
engages the viewer Mysteries are much
more fun when the audience gets a chance
to join in with wondering about the
events piecing together puzzles and the
like the way stories from inside the
nursery society and the outside world
are told side by side is just genius
allowing anime fans to use their brains
and just piece things together like the
mentioned shows there's has this eerie
and uncomfortable feeling hanging over
most of heavenly delusion and it
contrasts perfectly with more
light-hearted scenes there's some strong
character work as well and it works hand
inand with some of the more mature
themes that the anime showcases in its
narrative I won't exactly call Heavenly
delusion an under appreciated title from
its season since a lot of people I know
did take a crack at it however in terms
of qualtity it can more than stand
toe-to-toe with the Giants of 2023
without half the popularity of something
like say OSI no Co this anime is a real
gym that you should definitely
try here's Pluto taking this next spot
on the list the people who came into
watching Pluto may have done it out of
reputation with the renowned Name Behind
the anime someone could easily brush
Pluto off as a show living on reputation
but it's the real deal if you're out for
a mature sci-fi mystery that wrestles
with the idea of humans and robots
coexisting then you've come to the right
place Pluto keeps this narrative pretty
compact spanning Eight Episodes of an
hour each every moment filled with
scenes that either make you think or get
your heart pumping that's pretty much
what you like from a crime Thriller and
with the plethora of Cliffhangers it
won't take long for anyone to get hooked
seriously give Pluto a shot it may not
have as much hype as the biggest hits of
2023 but it is a true gem full of great
action and introspective
questions
[Music]
bleach marches on as one of the best of
2023 narrowly missing my top three
spot in what's become one of the
greatest revivals of the all we have
bleach maintaining its momentum with the
Thousand-Year blood War it's not an
understatement to say that a bit over
half a decade ago bleach's reputation
was in the gutter thanks to its final
Arc in the manga unanswered questions
and lots of rushing being the main
culprit thankfully though the anime has
filled in the holes and given us so much
more what I've said about the first part
of the Thousand-Year blood War holds
true for its second part which has gone
the extra mile in giving anime viewers
more lore and fights that were far
improved from their manga counterparts
all of a sudden a lot of the context and
the emotional Stakes for the Titanic
clashes in the ark started to make a lot
more sense bleach fans have been
feasting since the Thousand-Year blood
warar anime arrived and it will continue
for the foreseeable future but take note
we're just at the halfway point we've
still got an entire half of Bleacher
head a half which will no doubt add even
more background and layers to some of
the most intriguing characters Kubo ever
came up
with jiujitsu Kaizen season 2 takes the
next
[Music]
spot
I find it fitting to place bleach and
Jiu-Jitsu Kaiser next to each other one
glance and you can tell that the former
had a strong influence on the latter and
it just feels surreal that both are
airing in 2023 and both are at the peak
of their powers in terms of anime
adaptation I actually had a hard time
deciding which one to put over the other
so we can consider this a virtual tie
regardless Jiu-Jitsu Kaizen more than
deserves it spot here for how good
season 2's been having far and above
surpassed the goodness that is in the
first season given how much of a big
deal the first season was that is a high
bar to reach you know and season 2 did
it with one of the best arcs in Shonen
all together the shabuya arc is
everything you'd want from a big time
shown in Arc and Peak animation in the
key fights that will be remembered for
years to come it's crazy and that's
understating things not much more needs
to be said about the shuya arc so just
go and watch it
now to me
all in second place is Attack on Titan
the final
season now if you were to go back a
decade ago and tell me that the
thrilling show about humans standing up
and fighting against Unstoppable Titans
would turn out to be whatever this final
season has become I just wouldn't have
believed you yet at that time my gut
would also tell me that it's within the
realm of possibility Attack on Titan has
certainly come a long way and the
DraStic change in status quo in
preparation for this part of the final
season makes for an ultimate
confrontation to remember people have
been calling the final season the best
one so far and while that is debatable I
think it speaks to how well Attack on
Titan has transitioned as the goals of
of the story and the character's
motivations have changed compare this
season to the first one and you'll feel
like you're looking at a different show
given the DraStic shift in status quo
and overlying philosophy behind the
series it just speaks to how flexible
Attack on Titan is in giving
consistently immersive plot lines for
fans to follow while telling a message
through different lenses along with some
amazing work by the anime team in the
production Department this is the finale
that attack on Titan fans deserve
they've been waiting for this pretty
much for a decade and it's time to see
the thrilling conclusion
finishing up we have Vinland Saga my top
anime of
2023 it might be a pretty surprising
pick to many to a certain extent I've
made it no secret that I just love
Vinland Saga I really like the anime and
even had it as the best anime of 2019
but things have changed for the series
no longer is it about the dangerous and
daring Adventures through the Seas no
longer is it a gritty tale of Revenge
and internal Intrigue it's ended up
becoming a slice of life/ drama show so
what gives I'd argue that even in this
form Vinland saga continues to excel in
what it does best character writing the
change in genre might be jarring to a
lot of fans from 2019 and honestly
speaking I did feel that way too but if
you look past the fact that there's not
too much of the intense action anymore
the essence the key components of what
makes it so great they're actually still
there spectacular art that lets us take
in some breathtaking scenery methodical
plot points that help build character
and give us some time to reflect as well
as a lot of philosophical questions
imbued in the narrative Vin and Saga
actually feels like it's pushed the
bounds of what anime typically is and
that to me makes it deserving of this
spot as my best anime of
it's been a fun journey of reflection
and Nostalgia and I hope you've had fun
watching this video once again we of Vin
tube thank reverse 19999 for sponsoring
today's video click the link in the
description in order to get some release
perks hope to see you in game but before
you go you might want to drop by the
rest of the channel and look for videos
that might interest you till next time